- I just think that she's finding it
hard to understand why someone like me
would vote for someone like him, right?
- Yes. (laughing)
- It's hard, it's weird.
I don't know how to explain it.
Don't look at me with your killing eyes.
(laughing)
(whooshing and squeeking)
(light guitar music)
- My name is Kelsey and I
voted for Hillary Clinton.
Today, I came here with Dean
and Dean is my neighbor.
- I was in the United States Army,
and I served for five years
and I voted for Donald Trump.
- My name is Vanessa
and I voted for Hillary.
I'm here today with my boyfriend Jose.
- I voted for Donald Trump.
- So we're here to talk
about Hillary and Donald.
- Oh Donald.
- Yeah.
- What a guy.
- Yeah he's your guy.
- Well you know.
(laughing)
He's a guy, you know, he's a guy.
The decision to vote
for Trump was probably
the most difficult voting
decision I've ever made
in my entire life.
I don't like Trump as a human being.
I didn't make my actual decision
on who to vote for really
until the day of.
I didn't sleep that night.
- What made you vote for Trump
after we were oh yay for Hillary.
I felt really great going in
that day voting for Hillary.
We needed the change,
and needed some woman power there.
When I found out my
boyfriend had voted for Trump
I was extremely pissed.
- I told you the whole
shebang about like, you know,
what I know about him and ...
- All you read was,
or you watched a documentary. (laughing)
- No, she thinks I only
watched a documentary.
I knew so much more
before the documentary.
I decided to vote for Donald Trump
because he has a new,
fresh eye into politics.
He actually cares for this country
because he's like a super American.
He's like more proud of America
than he is of anything in the world.
Vanessa and I kind of talked about it,
but I kind of lied.
- He didn't tell me at all
who he voted for at the booth.
- I was trying to avoid argument.
- I had to find out when
he was a little bit tipsy
when we were with our friends
that he actually voted for Trump.
I was so hurt.
- I get that you voted for Trump.
You cared about his economic plans.
And the hard thing for
me of what I don't get,
some of the stuff that he's said
when it came to like women,
or when it came to just
like other groups of people.
- I've never been a woman in America.
I couldn't tell you not to be offended
by the things that he's said.
Kelsey and I are similar in a lot of ways
but different in a lot of ways.
She's from the mid-west.
I'm actually from New York,
but I lived in Texas for seven years.
I don't like his rhetoric,
I don't like the things
that he said about women,
but you never agree
with 100% of everything
that your candidate believes.
- I mean there are policies
that Bush or Romney
or, you know, McCain suggested,
that I wasn't necessarily on board with,
but I didn't feel offended by them.
That's what's different about this one.
- Completely understand that.
- What you don't understand
is that he's a celebrity.
So he's gonna like say things.
- That's why he shouldn't
be on the poll. (laughing)
- Listen to me, listen.
She's so confident in
what she believes in.
She's like really, like on it.
- All I know is Trump is not good.
- You only think he's not
good because of what he said.
- They were talking about Hispanics
and how he's so racist and everything,
and we're Hispanic.
He meant every word.
- I don't think so.
I know that he did make, you know,
some comments that were not,
they weren't nice,
but I'm very open-minded.
I was laughing about it.
I was like, this guy is so
dumb, he's just a celebrity.
He says like certain things
in order to create ratings
and in order to create suspense.
- My friends are like getting
harassed because of Trump.
- You know I would never do that.
I mean I wouldn't talk to people
the way he talks to people.
- I don't like Hillary.
The fact that she's done some
of the things that she's done.
The emails on her private server.
I mean let's not pretend
like that's not a big deal.
- I volunteered for her in Los Angeles.
She seemed like somebody
who was going to keep
progressing us forward,
especially in terms of social issues.
I totally get where you're coming from
'cause you have that military experience
and that's why I like to
talk to you about stuff.
And he says to John McCain,
"Oh I like people who don't get caught."
I'm like, is this the man that like,
the Republican Party believes is like
the best representative?
- I mean obviously I was frustrated too.
The thing for me.
It just went so farther
beyond like all the rhetoric
that was coming out of both sides
and I just did my best
to try to see past that
and see what I thought
the republican America
would look like over the
next four to eight years
as opposed to what the
Democratic Hillary Clinton
America would look like.
- It is hard because even now,
like, they even say, he doesn't
even know what he's doing
on the chair.
Like, he didn't know what
he was getting himself into.
And like he's just a mess.
She knew everything.
He knows nothing.
- Could you give me almost any other woman
who was qualified.
I would have been much more open
to having that discussion.
I'm not saying Hillary
needs to be in prison.
I'm not gonna run around
with a Hillary for Prison
sticker on my truck.
You know that I won't.
- For me to talk to him from
the perspective of, you know,
being a female might help
him learn about issues
with women's health
and with women's rights
that, you know, maybe just
aren't something he thinks about
in his day to day life.
I do think for a lot of
people, myself included,
I did not vote for Hillary
Clinton because she was a woman,
but it definitely seemed like
she understood women's issues
a lot more than Donald.
Even just on a policy level.
- What you're saying is like
'cause women are just nervous
that Trump is gonna roll back rights.
- Well, so if you want to
hear what I'm concerned about
like in terms of women's issues.
Some different aspects that
were covered by Obamacare
potentially would be rolled back
and then as far as like, you know,
the supreme court justice picks,
admitted that he would be
comfortable with electing people
who were okay with
overturning Roe v. Wade.
- I'm a republican.
I identify with republicans.
I do tend to lean more
toward like the middle.
At the end of the day I had
to align myself with my party
and have faith that
they're not gonna let him do crazy things
when he's in office.
As far as the supreme court
justices and the Roe v. Wade,
that's (exhaling).
I can't,
as a guy, I can't tell you
not to be worried about that
or how to feel.
I don't even think I could
possibly understand how you feel.
- Yeah.
It's like scary.
- Yeah that's one of those things,
I mean I can just kind of be
a friend and be there for you.
- She knows who I am
and she knows that ultimately
if I made a mistake
or if something like bad is happening,
I will do whatever I can
to help the situation.
- I'm glad that we get
to get it off our chest.
I do know, Jose, the way you say.
It's just that little like,
like that little one little percenter.
You like question, like what wait,
what the puck is going on over here.
- If there was something crazy happening,
you were put at risk,
like I would be the first one
standing there next to you
to fight that same battle with you.
Because equality matters,
like rights, human rights matter.
- I never said that I
didn't agree that, you know,
he's cocky, arrogant.
But I said at least, you know,
since it's already happening, you know,
might as well just like go along with it.
Kind of like when you go to the doctor
and they tell you you have like cancer
and you have like six months to live.
What are you gonna do?
Like,
the best thing to do is just like
kind of do the best you can.
- If you're somebody who
felt strongly about
this political election
and have people that you
care about in your lives
that you want to talk to about it,
I think it's important to
find out where they came from
and research their perspective.
- Voice your opinion for one.
- We're already in this and
the best thing we can do
is help each other, support each other.
I don't really think
it's worth the arguments
and the fights.
Because at the end of the day,
you're not gonna be
able to change anything.
The only thing you can
change is your relationship.
- It's tough to get perspective
if you don't put yourself
in that environment
and have those conversations.
You can't be afraid to
have these conversations.
'Cause conversation is what sparks change.
When I get to sit down
and so my eyes get opened
and I get a better perspective of things.
It's what drives our nation forward.
She baked a bangin' cake.
I was about to go and
get some of this cake.
It had Hillary's face all over it.
She didn't let me have any of that cake.
- 'Cause I ate it all.
It wasn't 'cause I kept it from you.
(whooshing and creaking)